un enfant de 12 ans séquestré violé
asphyxié tué par une personne en
situation irrégulière et expulsable
depuis le 30 septembre 2022 ça vous
dirait de faire votre boulot
voilà la question est assez cash c'est
ce qui va se passer ce soir qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à ça monsieur ministre
d'abord je veux dire que personne peut
se mettre à la place des parents de Lola
d'abord une enfant violet et tué je
pense que tout le monde quand on est
père de famille comme je suis j'ai deux
enfants
pensent que c'est ce qu'elle puisse
ignoble
et à ce monsieur et à tous ceux qui se
posent la question moi je comprends leur
colère je veux aussi dire que je veux
aussi les persuader que moi je rentre
pas le soir où je vais pas le matin en
me disant tiens je fais un boulot comme
les autres puis qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui l'enfant s'est fait
tuer ça me fait rien je fais de la
politique pour éviter ça parfois on a
des échecs et à chaque fois qu'il y a la
mort de quelqu'un à chaque fois qu'elle
assassinat d'enfant et un échec de la
politique qui a des chèques de la
société il y a un échec de la politique
évidemment et mise intérieure est
responsable